حسناً نحن نعمل بجد
لتحقيق وقف إطلاق النار وأعتقد أن
نتائج تصعيد
العنف
وخسائر في الأرواح والدمار أه
تحتم بالتأكيد
بذل كل الجهود لتحقيق
وقف إطلاق النار
لتجنب التصعيد وتجنب اتساع
أه  الصراع
كانت جهودنا متسقة في هذا
الصدد ،
لقد تواصلت مع جميع الأطراف
المعنية أه
تكلمت مع الوزير أشكنازي. لقد تحدثت
إلى الوزير طرفة عين مجموعة متنوعة من
وزراء الخارجية من الاتحاد الأوروبي
هناك قدر كبير من الاهتمام مرة أخرى
وزراء خارجية دول
تنظيم مؤتمر إسلامي
ونواصل التنسيق مع جميع
شركائنا لتحقيق وقف إطلاق النار
لمنع التصعيد المستمر وما يترتب على
ذلك
من خسائر في الأرواح من أو ما
يعيق اتفاق وقف إطلاق النار في هذه المرحلة
نحن نعمل
أه بجد  مع جميع الأطراف
المعنية
ونأمل أن نكون عاجلاً وليس آجلاً
في وضع إيجابي  لإعلان وقف إطلاق النار
ولتخفيف التوترات الحالية ،
قمنا بإجراء مشاورات وثيقة
مع الإسرائيليين مع السلطة الفلسطينية
مع حماس
ولدينا تطمينات
بأن الفلسطينيين حريصون على
حل هذا التصعيد.